Valyria was not the first to conquer the
world in the dawn of days the city of
geese opened its gates and poured forth
its legions across the continent of
Essos with their lockstep discipline and
absolute obedience they ground entire
nations beneath their boots and planted
the harpy in every corner of the known
world what they didn't destroy they
chained slavery is as old as man but
until the ghiscari it was never an art
the slave Lords grew rich and fat as
pyramids were raised around them
pleasure houses were filled and fighting
pits were opened
nobody remembers if the waters around
geese had names before the Empire but
ever since we know them only as slavers
Bay and the Gulf of grief of geese
however nothing remains but ruins where
and all great civilizations 5,000 years
ago Valyrian Shepherds stumbled on
strange eggs and within a few
generations an upstart Valyrian freehold
rose across the sea five times did the
ghiscari contend with Valyria and five
times did they go down in defeat for the
freehold had dragons and the
none the best of their legions burned
the others broke the brick walls of dese
were pulled down the streets and
buildings turned to ash and the very
fields sewn with salt sulfur and skulls
yet the Empire was not wholly destroyed
Astor poor young Kai and marine one
slowly colonies along slavers Bay
survived and even thrived Valyria had
watched the ghiscari grow rich and
powerful off the backs of conquered
peoples and now the self-styled freehold
wanted its turn while the Dragonlords
brought the world to heel the slave
markets of their former enemy never
lacked for flesh lamenting the lost
Empire the descendants of all geese grew
rich and fat the doom fell on Valyria
and the Dothraki rose to pillage most of
the continent at will but gold-laden
Astapor yunkai and marine continue as
they have for thousands of years
untouched for even the horselords
understand what the ghiscari taught
Valeria's so long ago what good are
slaves without slavers